[Musique]
grande surprise ce matin pour ne pas
dire stupéfaction à la conférence des
présidents
vous avez refusé monsieur le président
notre demande de rendre hommage avec une
minute de silence à cette infirmière tué
dans l'exercice de ses fonctions
je n'aurais donc pas de questions
gouvernement et propose avec mon groupe
pour le temps restant de mon
intervention d'observer une minute de
silence en hommage à cette soignante
madame fiat nous sommes tous sensibles à
l'émotion provoquée par le drame que
vous venez d'évoquer mai ainsi que je
lai indiqué au président de votre groupe
lusage limite la pratique des minutes de
silence à des cas exceptionnels et
solennelle et une petit à voir dans cet
hémicycle d'une minute de silence à
l'initiative d'un député ou d'un groupe
votre ministre la santé abandonnent le
navire en pleine tempête
elle a démissionné alors que la crise du
coronavirus continuent de faire planer
une inquiétude sur notre capacité à
faire face à une épidémie de grande
ampleur
contrairement d'autres ministres en
campagne elle a décidé de se consacrer à
la campagne municipale à paris une façon
bien commode de ne pas assumer son bilan
catastrophique à la tête du ministère
je voudrais intervenir suite à
l'interpellation de ma collègue caroline
fille à tout à l'heure pour m'associer à
la tristesse de la nation suite au décès
de l'infirmière at war cette jeune
infirmière de 31 ans mère de deux
enfants qui a été poignardé à mort par
un patients psychotiques
dès le lendemain le délégué ministériel
à la santé mentale s'est rendu sur place
et je me rendrai moi même sur place dans
les prochains jours at war s'empresse à
la rencontre des équipes parce que je
pense que c'est mon rôle que dit à
l'aise
vous inquiète et je peux le comprendre
de la suite qui sera donnée à la prise
en charge de la crise du coronavirus
sachez que j'étais hier à l'hôpital
bichat à la rencontre des équipements
quotidien soigne les malades au
quotidien s'assure que la sécurité que
la santé des français soit garanti j'ai
reçu ce matin soixante responsable de la
santé de ville et de l'hôpital pour
faire le point avec eux avec la
direction générale de la santé
la maison est tenu l'honnêteté devrait
vous pousser à reconnaître que dans ce
dossier le gouvernement fait preuve d'
autant d'arrogance que d'autoritarisme
arrogance lorsque vous répéter aux
français qu'ils n'y comprennent rien
autoritarisme lorsque vous imposer un
texte aux députés qui prévoit un calcul
et une revalorisation des pensions avec
un indice gazeux qui reste à inventer
celui du revenu moyen d'activités par
tête
les français auront donc connaissance
des effets de ce nouvel indice sur leur
retraite qui n'existe pas encore
après seulement le vote du projet de loi
c'est un peu comme si vous demandiez aux
français de monter dans un train pour
une destination inconnue avec le prix du
billet connu lui seulement à l'arrivée
nous construisons un système universel
où tous les français tous les actifs
auront leur place et il est donc
nécessaire que le point monsieur forme
arriver là madame du jour la réponse
d'un revenu d'un indicateur qui est le
revenu d'activité par tête et ce revenu
d'activité par tête sera composé à près
de 70% par le salaire moyen par tête car
70% des actifs français sont les
salariés
comme vous le savez bien et cela ne doit
donc pas vous poser à mon avis beaucoup
plus de questions
la radicalisation dans les prisons d'en
parler monsieur meyer habib elle n'est
pas née en 2012 avec l'élection de
monsieur françois hollande elle existait
avant 2012 et c'est en 2014 qui a été
créé un service du renseignement
pénitentiaire il existait des objectifs
terroristes qui ont été suivis comme il
se doit par les services sauf qu'ils
sont partis se battre en syrie en irak
pour ensuite nous attaquer voilà un
sujet où il faut faire preuve de
modestie d'humilité ce sujet c'est la
défense de la république et il doit nous
unir et nous
pour tous êtres uniques derrière cette
politique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]